thank you Mercedes I love the San
Gennaro Feast and I also love the neon
Museum so the neon museum has a new
artist in Residence and he is here with
us today we are so excited to have
Thomas putsier join us to tell us all
about his artistic talents Thomas thank
you for being here oh thank you for
having me congratulations how does it
feel to be the new artist in residence
for the neon musing and that's a huge
honor I know it's the most iconic Museum
in the city and I'm just thrilled so we
were talking a little bit about the
process of this and you go through a
submission process and they chose you
love everyone else tell us a little bit
about your artistic style I know you're
all about inclusivity right yeah you
know I'm really looking at geometry as a
coded language to create story and much
of my work features architectural
figures being painting or large-scale
sculpture so I'm just thrilled to work
with this organization well we're seeing
some really cool photos on our screen
here and how are you planning to kind of
tie that into our Vegas atmosphere and
The Vibes of the neon Museum yeah you
know right now I'm doing an introductory
week and I'm just kind of getting to
experience the city and its art and the
culture so I'm kind of in the midst of
figuring out which direction I want to
take the art I'm going to make and you
don't live here early where are you from
I'm from Minneapolis Minnesota okay
okay really cool because we are getting
kind of an side perspective look into
our city do you find that to be
difficult or kind of a challenge that
you're up to to learn more about our
history here definitely a challenge I'm
up to
um I really am interested in the
comprehensive view of the city and I've
been taking in as much as I can while
I've been here I've been lucky to walk
the strip and do a lot of hiking at Red
Rock and explore the museum and I feel
like you have such a creative and unique
approach even just looking at a few of
your examples of work there where do you
find your creativity and kind of how did
it all start for you yeah I I love
looking at form in its simplest context
so I really like combining
simple forms like triangles and circles
and squares into new shapes and new work
and creating new meaning out of things
that already exist that's such a cool
process and I'm excited to see more so
you're kind of in that onboarding
process but next year really we'll get
to see some of your work like up close
and personal right yeah I would say
early spring oh we can't wait to see you
well congratulations thank you this
really is a huge huge honor yes thank
you on Museum and we can't wait to see
all of your work thank you so much for
being here and Alaska